[Music]
hi everyone it's Charlie hopefully
you've had a chance to see spider-man
far from home I've got a lot of messages
about possible references to some really
big cosmic things I'll try to address
that in this Easter eggs video I'll also
talk about what's going on with Marvel's
comic-con panel which is happening in a
couple weeks it's gonna be 90 minutes
long so there's gonna be a lot of Marvel
phase 4 stuff that they revealed during
that we're doing an IMAX ticket giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a spider-man
comment on the video
so obviously spoiler warning if you have
not seen spider-man far from home yet
there are so many Easter eggs and so
many references but we have to talk
about the post-credits scene and some of
the really big ones so in the final
post-credit scene it's revealed that
Nick Fury is on the sword Space Station
from the comics teasing some really big
Marvel phase for cosmic things to come
it's probably one of the most
mind-blowing things that they do with
the movie it starts as a funny joke but
then as you start to realize what it
really means for the future it becomes
even crazier so there's a line earlier
in the film that now people are reading
in this more cosmic context that seems
like it's winking more at Silver Surfer
so before the big final fight between
spider-man and Mysterio happy is flying
Peter to London on the plane to stop
Mysterio save his friends he reveals the
special suit fabrication device hidden
in the back of the plane Peter starts
making his new steve ditko spider-man
suit while happy plays the ac/dc back in
black as an homage to Ironman listening
to ac/dc and building his original Iron
Man suits they have that funny moment I
love Led Zeppelin because Peter doesn't
totally understand all classic rock
bands as they approach the city they
need to warn Nick Fury and Maria hill
that Mysterio has been lying to them
this whole time and he's behind the
elemental attacks but Mysterio is using
the Edith glasses to monitor all their
phones and communications so happy' has
to use a special secret code to let Nick
Fury know what's really going on
so after happy drops spider-man in the
fake storm he has that funny moment we
need to have a serious conversation
about you and my Aunt May after this
happy calls Nick Fury's phone to warn
him who has this funny reaction at the
sight of happy who the hell are you yeah
yeah I know let's get on with this
there's this big joke in the movie about
Nick Fury and phones in general
Peter ducking his calls ghosting him
sending him straight to voicemail
Mysterio even ghosts Nick Fury at the
end of the
on the comms right before the big London
Tower Bridge fight because evil henchmen
he's been using to create all his
dialogue doesn't come up with a new
excuse for him to give Nick Fury fast
enough oh that's some [ __ ] but the
thing that everyone's been calling the
Silver Surfer Easter Egg is Happy's
actual coded message to Nate fury this
is what he says so the messages
apparently mr. stark was going through
his belongings and there was a surfboard
you left behind people over there said
Nick Fury is not really a surfer Tony
said appearances can be deceiving Nick
Fury responds with the corresponding
coded answer to the message angrily
saying the surfboard isn't mine don't
ever call this number again then hangs
up so everyone is just thinking that the
mention of the surfboard is so utterly
specific when they could have said
anything in that message that it's
Marvel winking at Silver Surfer he's a
fantastic four character there have been
lots of rumors about a Fantastic Four
reboot movie coming before they reboot
the x-men characters you may remember
talked about a Silver Surfer movie being
in development or being talked about way
back before Avengers end game came out
Kevin Feige actually did an interview
clarifying that Adam McKay who's done a
lot of cleanup work on ant-man and
earlier movies for them helped him out
with little minor jams that they've been
in has talked about wanting to do a
Silver Surfer movie this is the clip of
Kevin Feige talking about that I don't
know if you heard I spoke to McKay the
other day Adam McKay said Silver Surfer
movie I might you know I might need to
give Feige a call have you gotten the
call I've not gotten a call yet but I've
seen Adam tonight and at a number of
these awards and he is not only as
everybody knows incredibly smart guy
he's a honest-to-goodness fan and and
you know he did a lot of sort of behind
the scenes help with us on the first
hand man film and have you seen Vice
cameo little practice cameo in there if
we helped him get so I look forward to
speaking with him more
is there is there a Fox property or
you're just excited to potentially get
your hands on particular that the truth
is I'm excited for all of them I'm
excited and it's not just the marquee
names you know there are hundreds of
names on those on those documents on
those agreements and the fact that
Marvel is as close as we may ever get
now to having access to all of the
characters is something I've been
dreaming about for my almost 20 years at
Marvel and it's very exciting so taking
that all in it's clear that Marvel is
thinking a lot about Silver Surfer
separately from x-men and Fantastic Four
stuff I wouldn't be surprised if there's
a lot of talks going on behind the
scenes so you could take that special
coded Nick Fury happy Hogan message as a
Silver Surfer Easter Egg but I also
think part of that joke with the
surfboard about Nick Fury being a surfer
is them setting up the post credit scene
joke of him being on the beach in that
Tahiti like simulation enjoying some
vacation downtime between threats which
was the whole reason that he asked Talos
and his wife to use their scroll powers
to stand in for him on earth and hand
off Iron Man's Edith glasses to
spider-man now they have that big joke
during the post-credits scene where
Talos is like you know yeah we gave the
kid the glasses like you said but then
things kind of went off the rails and
you really need to come back people were
asking where the Avengers what do I tell
them I have no idea where the Avengers
are so Nick Fury is like okay fine
everybody back to work chop chop has
anyone seen my shoes so if they're doing
all this big cosmic stuff in the
post-credits scene would it make sense
that they also have some funny cosmic
jokes earlier in the film - the only
issue I see with them doing Silver
Surfer Easter eggs this early is that
the movie was shot before the Fox Disney
deal had closed and until that had
happened they legally weren't allowed to
reference or talk about any x-men or
Fantastic Four stuff yes
technically the rights to the fantastic
four movies and those characters were
never owned by Fox they're owned by
Constantine films it's just that God
Satine films had an ongoing long-term
distribution deal with Fox so when all
the Fox Marvel characters came back to
Marvel after the buyout deal closed it's
safe to assume that Marvel would have
also made separate arrangements to
secure the Fantastic Four characters
even if Constantine films were locked
into a long-term distribution deal with
Fox that was all rendered moot
when Disney bought Fox in the deal
closed worst case scenario with the
future fantastic for movies is that
Marvel has to do a similar sharing deal
with that studio as it does with Sony in
the spider-man characters just to put
that into context right now Sony is
getting ready to have its first
spider-man movie to make a billion
dollars worldwide with spider-man far
from home it's on track to earn a
billion dollars worldwide all Marvel has
to do when it negotiates with these
other studios that still have some
residual rights to certain characters is
say a billion dollars just hold up a
sign with a billion dollars on it and
tell them you're never going to make
this kind of money trying to make your
own movie with these characters so just
let us use them however we want we'll
share some of the money with you and you
don't have to do jack [ __ ] just sit
there and cash the checks that we send
you so moving into comic-con Marvel just
confirmed their big comic-con Hall H
panel for Saturday night in a couple
weeks that's their normal night that
they always do it on it's going to be 90
minutes long that's huge that means
Black Widow movie preview maybe some
footage because they're still filming it
right now short preview for the Eternals
movie they haven't started shooting that
yet but it's supposed to be the next big
movie in Marvel phase 4 after the Black
Widow movie next year they might bring
some Avengers back for a special
celebratory moment on stage like look at
all the awesome stuff that we did in the
last 10 years probably a full schedule
of Marvel phase 4 films for just the
next four years we know what most of
those are maybe they'll announce
spider-man 3 which should come out in
2021 which is two years from now we
actually just got some news that Kraven
might be one of the villains of that
movie including the Scorpion because
they'll be coming back they weren't in
spider-man far from home but there are a
couple of villains left over at the end
of a spider-man homecoming that will
come back for spider-man 3 it's on our
little spider friend I've got some boys
on the outside who would love to meet
them you know take a picture slice his
throat put his head in the dryer don't
worry I'll do separate videos about
spider-man 3 and the spider-man stuff
happening in Marvel phase 4 later this
week but they might also do a new
preview for the Marvel phase for
Avengers spin-off TV series like the
Falcon Winter Soldier series where
Falcon has already become Captain
America The Scarlet Witch vision series
and then the Hawkeye
they still have not confirmed that
they're doing a Hawkeye series but all
the Hollywood trades have reported that
it's in development and even Jeremy
Renner was talking about it at recent
convention appearances very very small
chance that they announced when their
Fantastic Four reboot movie is going to
happen or at least that they're working
on it even if it doesn't have a hard
release date yet which I don't think
that it does and maybe maybe an updated
timeline on what's going on with new
x-men characters coming in but Kevin Bai
he already said that it would be a long
time before x-men characters started
appearing in Marvel movies so that might
not happen till the very end of Marvel
phase four early phase five like say
four or five years down the road it's
gonna be a while many many many secrets
many many many secrets will be would be
ideal and I think the Disney marketing
team is the best in the world and will
be able to pull it off so like I said
I'm working on a spider-man 3 teaser
video in more easter-egg videos those be
coming later this week if you have any
big questions that you want me to do
bonus videos about just let me know in
the comments
congratulations next legacy your the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
click here for the spider-man far from
home post credits scenes and click here
for that full spider-man far from home
Easter eggs video thank you so much for
watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]